a common sight across parts of Europe
this month this is the takeoff for
another rescue operation in Austria
late on Saturday night three German
skiers were killed in an avalanche near
the mountain village of lek a fourth man
remains missing and for now searches
have been halted yeah this is Ichiko
very moment the risk would be far too
high for the rescue teams at the moment
yesterday evening we decided to stop the
search because it had become too
dangerous we know how the weather is
developing we can probably only think
about continuing the search on Wednesday
haven't you heard the group who came
from southern Germany were reported
missing by one of their wives on
Saturday night thousands of people visit
this exclusive ski resort every year but
the advice from locals and Ski experts
is to remain on track when weather
conditions are poor use your guides in
the destination to go off piste clean
and to do off piste clean but at the
moment is a clear recommendation from
our side not to ski off piste Austria
has seen record snowfall with more
expected throughout the week soldiers
firefighters and volunteers have been
battling to clear cut off roads and
rooftops during breaks in the weather
elsewhere across Europe three people
were injured in Switzerland after an
avalanche engulfed a packed hotel over
in France two employees at the Maryland
Ski Resort died when the Avalanche
control charges they were trying to set
accidentally went off these victims
bring the number of weather-related
deaths in parts of Europe this month to
at least 26 back in western Austria the
search for the missing man will continue
on Wednesday for now locals and rescue
operators can only wait for the adverse
weather to subside Inzamam rashid sky
news